في عمليه انقاذ جريئه ونادره استخدم رجال
الاطفاء في نيويورك حبلا لانقاذ امراه
كانت تتدلى من الطابق ال 20 لمبنى سكني
بمنطقه منعه بعد انطلاق اندلاع حريق في
شقتها وشوه ذات المراه في الفيديو الذي
يحبس الانفاس معلقه خارج نافذه الشقه
بينما يتصاعد الدخان ويحاصرها رجال
الاطفاء
[موسيقى]
تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بين
مصر مقطع فيديو مؤثر يظهر ام المصريات
تدعوا لابنها من اعماق قلبها في الحرم
المكي وسط الالاف من الطائفين حول الكعبه
وانتشر المقطع على نطاق واسع عبر مواقع
التواصل مثيرا موجه كبيره من التعاطف
والاعجاب من المستخدمين
عشان اقول لك اهو تبع الخضره
يا رب يا رب وريحني ريح قلبه يا رب انا
راضي عن ابني يا رب
دخله الجنه يا رب
يا رب
ريحني يا رب تعبني
اثارت حادثه تزويج طفله قاصر في اليمن ضجه
واسعه على مواقع التواصل اجتماعي الطفله
تدعى نهى جميل من سكان مديريه دمت وتبلغ
من العمر عشره اعوام وتشير التفاصيل الى
انه تم تزويق تزوير عمر الطفله في الاوراق
الرسميه وبعد اكتشاف الحادثه تم القبض على
الوالد الفتاوى الزوج والامين الشرعي وقدت
محكمه دمت الابتدائيه بفسق عقد زواج
الطفله واعادتها لامها
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء